hi everybody thanks for coming back to
those of you who came last night and
thanks for coming tonight for those of
you who were not able to make it last
night my name is John Wilkins I'm on the
faculty at the Institute and it is a
tremendous pleasure and honor to be able
to introduce Nina Federoff tonight for
the second of these long lectures for
those of you well I'm not going to go
through the CV because as you know David
did I think ample justice to her
extensively honorable CV last night and
and and the highlights you've actually
got on that little piece of paper that
they handed that to you were coming in
but I would like to just sort of try to
bridge very briefly for those of you who
were able to make it last night
you'll recall that Nina talked about
let's see I feel like what I want to say
that I came away with most strongly is
Wow have I really underestimated plants
and and it's really it's really a yeah
you know and she talked about how plants
do all these things that are sort of
analogous to things that we really
imagine being specifically the purview
of animals that they in some sense they
see in some sense they smell in some
sense they feel and and the thing is you
know I think and anybody who works in
something like plants will tell you you
know of course both in the scientific
community and in you know in our lives
in general we're we're very animal
centric and we tend not to think about
things like plants that much and so very
often is the case that the sort of our
understanding of things that are less
like us lags far far behind our
understanding of things that are more
like us and so of course the structure
of a lot of last night's lecture was
really you know here are these things
that you thought were special about you
but but look you and the one recent
decades we've we've started to
understand how plants do similar things
one of the things that I think is really
exciting about tonight's material is
this is sort of a set of discoveries and
ideas that have radically revolutionized
our our notion
of what a gene is of what an
individuality is of how evolution works
and these are actually the sexually an
area where discoveries within the plant
domain led the way and it wasn't until
later that we discovered well actually
these things may be what she's going to
be talking about tonight are universal
and apply also to to animals and I'm not
gonna go on none because I think that
Nina's itch and get up here and and and
digging on some science but but I do
want to just say one thing which because
I think based on what I know if
tonight's lecture and and in last
night's lecture I think one thing that I
suspect will be notice ly lacking from
from the content of the lecture tonight
I wanted to point out which is you know
she's going to talk to you tonight about
some things discoveries in the past
hundred and particularly the past fifty
years like say they've really
revolutionized the way that we think
about life all up and down the thing
that she is probably not going to
adequately emphasize is the importance
of the role that she herself has played
in these discoveries and the extent to
which these revolutions have have
depended on work that was done by her by
her collaborators and by her students
and I say those of you who saw the the
talk last night will have noted this
sort of it was it was sort of a very
historical view but if you were paying
attention there was an enormous amount
of that work that was actually she's
directly responsible for so I will not
go on and on but let me just introduce
Nina Federoff again
thank you very much John that was very
nice
so this is where we left off last night
so this evening we start with the
fundamentals of plant sex how plants
reproduce is a bit different from how
animals do it yes there's a negative
sperm and embryos formed when they fuse
that's all the stuff that's going on
inside of the flower
these are the male and female
reproductive organs and for some reason
this is not advanced I'll just start
where we left off okay so I'm gonna let
this run through because it's just so
beautiful so on the right it is a
close-up of the reproductive organs of
the flower those are the stamens those
make the male sex cells and this is the
pistil this is the female part of the
reproductive organs so let's look a
little closer this is a scanning
electron micrograph of a stamen which
produces the pollen grains themselves
and if you look even closer that's what
it looks like and each one of those
pollen grains is rather remarkable sell
each pollen grain is itself a cell with
its own nucleus that's the central part
and inside of it although you only see
one the very dense staining material is
the sperm cell so it's Tuesday and
there's actually two of them in higher
plants and so there are two cells inside
of a third cell now on the female side
this whole central structure is the
pistil this is the female reproductive
organ and at the top is a structure
called the stigma it's sticky and that's
where the pollen
here's when it lands here you see simply
an anther close by and a few pollen
grains on the stigma now pollen arrives
worn by wind or delivered by an insect
the showing us the wonderful fragrances
and the nectar czar flowers or how they
seduce birds and insects to do the work
of spreading their genes far and wide
now here's a diagram that shows the
structure the pistol itself here are the
stigma at the top that's where that is
connected by very long tube the style
that collects this is the stigma that
collects the pollen here's the style and
at the bottom is the ovary which
contains the egg cell now when a pollen
grain falls on the stigma it germinates
that is it begins to send out a very
long tube and that tube gets longer and
longer because the tube has to grow all
the way down through this long style to
reach the ovary and fertilize the egg
cell now here's a tube pollen tube
elongating and you see it has a little
nucleus of its own that kind of supports
it but there are two sperm nuclei up
here they're called nuclei but actually
they're complete cells and they will
follow down that tube and here actually
is a picture this is an incredible an
incredible cell it's probably one of the
fastest growing cells on the face of the
earth and here you see this is actually
a time last picture but not that the
frames are taken pretty close together
in fact if you think about it the style
on the on a corn plant is actually the
silk and it can be a foot long it can be
even longer than that and this pollen
tube grows so fast on that tube when it
lands on the silk that it can can cover
12 inches in just a few hours so on the
left in the next diagram is a mature
ovary
it consists of an egg cell and a number
of other cells the egg cell is right in
the center maybe I should use this
there's the egg cell there's some
additional cells here and this is a the
female reproductive structure all of
these cells are actually have only one
copy of each gene they are this is the
what's called the female haploid
generation plants actually alternate
generations are diploid in the haploid
phase diploid simply means it has
chromosomes from both parents haploid
means it has only one copy of each
chromosome we'll get two chromosomes I
sometimes have to get ahead of where I
am a bit but you'll see and perhaps
you'll remember now it's important for
the subsequent discussion of genetics
that you know that both the sperm cell
and the egg cell contain only half as
much genetic information as all the rest
of the cells you know that you get genes
from your father and your mother you in
turn donate one of those genes to your
offspring which received the rest from
the other parent the same is true in
plants so the sperm cells as I just said
have one copy of each chromosome and the
egg cells have one of each kind
now when the pollen tube lands and
reaches the ovary it's growing down
through the style it delivers to sperm
cells into one of them fuses with the
egg cell and the other one fuses with
what's called a polar nucleus it's
actually a pair of nuclei so the mother
contributes two sets of genetic
information and the resulting cell
develops into the nutritive part of the
seed oops sorry
there we go the vast majority of the
seed is this endosperm that contains the
starch and the proteins that will
nourish the little growing plant as it
emerges underground before it can reach
the light it must have light to make its
own food so it goes on these stored
reserves and then here is the embryo
you've probably had the experience of
eating sweet corn there's a little
slippery shield-shaped thing in each
kernel of sweet corn and that's the
embryo that's the baby plant now the
reason that I'm telling you this is it
turns out very important a very
important property which makes plants
and particularly corn I will use the
term corn and possibly maize I'm not
I've used them interchangeably corn is
known as maize in many parts of the
world and in the scientific community it
is known as maize but the important part
here is that the genetic material that's
in the endosperm is exactly the same as
that in the embryo that means that the
kernel is a little window on the next
generation and that makes it marvelously
useful organism for genetic studies now
modern-day genetics started in an
Augustinian monastery in the late 1800s
one of the monks a man by the name of
Gregor Mendel did some experiments with
garden peas
Mendel was a very highly educated man he
became a monk in 1843 and was ordained
as a priest several days later then he
went off to Vienna to study physics and
Natural Sciences for a couple of years
after he came back to the toy boy stur
he taught and in 1856 he he began the
studies on plant hybridization that had
become famous as the origins of
contemporary genetics he published his
results in a relatively obscure journal
in 1865 even though hybridization was an
active area of research at the time his
results got very little attention for
the next several decades just they just
didn't fit very well with other people's
other scientists ideas of how heredity
works what his studies were on was the
inherence of very simple traits such as
the color of peas yellow a green or
whether they were wrinkled around the
reason his work didn't much impact
didn't have much impact at the time was
that the field of inheritance was
dominated by biome attrition snow this
is the first meeting of biome attrition
biometrics today biometrics means
something very different
these folks generally thought that the
properties of parents were mixed
together kind of like mixing red and
white paint to give pink paint so that
the offspring were some kind of a blend
of their parents traits but this isn't
at all what happens in fact the first
thing that Mendel documented rigorously
was that one of the traits just plain
disappears in the hybrid I'm going to
show you what Mendel saw but I'm gonna
use corn simply because the ear provides
such a beautiful genetic display I will
remind you that because of the double
fertilization event the kernel is
genetically the same as the embryonic
plant inside of it so what Mendel saw
many cross plants with contrasting
traits like this is that one of the
traits as I said simply disappeared in
the first daughter generation and that's
called the f1 that property of
disappearance of one trait was referred
to as dominance the trait that doesn't
disappear that dominates that masks the
other trait is called dominant the other
one is called recessive now the second
thing that Mendel documented was that
the trait that disappeared reappeared in
the next generation in a very regular
way three-quarters of the colonel's
a red and a quarter or white
that's called segregation here's how it
looks on an ear now for the moment you
have to ignore the spots on the kernels
I'll get those to those later but you
can see that basically the red and white
are about three
now here's how it happens each parent
has two copies of the gene for the
pigment the color genes - reds - whites
and of course it donates only one of
those copies to the offspring so the
first generation has one red gene and
one white gene so all of them are red
now when you cross two such plants to
each other
remember only one copy goes to the
offspring so you can get a red gene from
poppin are edging from mama that's gonna
be a red offspring you can get a white
gene from Papa red gene from Mama and
vice versa so there's two ways of
getting a copy of a red gene and a white
gene and then the only way that you can
possibly get white offspring is by
having two copies of the white gene
that's the segregation now he further
looked at the relationship of different
traits to each other we call them genes
now
genetic traits and the three-two-one
segregation is observed for all kinds of
traits now here you have round and
starchy kernels the the round kernels
are starchy and the wrinkled ones that's
sweet corn that can't convert the sugar
to starch the round trait is dominant to
the wrinkled trait and segregates
three-to-one in the f2 generation as you
see in the central ear now you can get a
combination of red and wrinkled but if
you bring together both of these traits
round and red they're both dominant so
the f1 is round in red and then in the
f2 that's the second generation they
segregate as follows each one segregates
individually at 3 to 1
that if you count both traits that gives
you nine round red to three white and
round two three wrinkled and red to just
one wrinkled white see so each trait in
itself segregates three to one and the
combination gives you that nine to three
two three to one ratio now one of the
reasons that Mendel's work didn't have
much of an impact at the time is that it
just struck scientists at that but that
it was just too simple several decades
later however two very important
geneticists you could raise and Carl
Correns simultaneously did the same
experiments originally not knowing about
Mendel's work and then they started
reading the literature and despite the
fact that they didn't have Google and
MEDLINE both found Mendel's original
1960 or 1865 publication and realized
that he made exactly the same
discoveries now
both brought attention to Mendel's work
so that by the early 20th century the
Mendelian rules had become central to
the new breed of scientist and only
later were these called genes they were
called units of inheritance at the time
and only later were the scientists to
become geneticists now genetics hae a
very active field in the early 20th
century and it soon became clear that
Mendel's segregation law didn't always
apply because genes travel in packs
stuck to each other corn for plants and
fruit flies were favorite organisms for
genetic investigations and studies early
in the century established that the
units of heredity the genes were linked
together in what were originally called
linkage groups by the 1930s it was clear
that the tangled strands inside of cell
nuclei these were originally named
chromosomes because they really readily
took up a certain kind of dye and these
tangled threads were themselves the
chromosomes and the I mean the linkage
groups now it isn't the case that
all the genes on a chromosome always
stay together because the chromosome
trade pieces in a process called
recombination during the development of
sex cells I'll show you that in a moment
but the essential point here is that
each chromosome has lots and lots of
genes on it and they tend to be
inherited together to some extent now
during the 1930s and 40s when
geneticists were busy mapping genes that
is figuring out where they were relative
to each other along the chromosomes
biochemists figured out that chromosomes
consists both of proteins and of a long
polymer called deoxyribonucleic acid
better known as DNA and a good deal of
time and energy went into arguing about
whether it was the DNA or the protein
that was the hereditary material for the
most part people favored the idea that
it was proteins because they were much
more complicated they consisted of 20
different amino acids and came in many
different forms while DNA was pretty
simple it consisted of just four
building blocks the variable parts of
which were adenine thymine guanine and
cytosine you've probably seen the
letters ATG and C now just about the
middle of the century there were two big
revolutions the first of which was
catalyzed by these two brash young lads
Jim Watson on the left and Francis Crick
on the right they published a little
paper in 1953 that suggested a structure
for DNA that made it immediately obvious
how it could be the hereditary material
specifically what they suggested was
that DNA was a double-stranded structure
with its two sugar phosphate bath bones
on the outside and the bases facing each
other in the center paired up in a very
specific way such that a always paired
with T and G always paired with see this
in turn suggested a very precise copying
method mechanism in which the two
strands come apart in each strand acts
as a template for the construction of a
new molecule and that's what you see
here in this
the chromosomes then are highly
compacted DNA molecules wound up around
proteins and further compacted in super
coils now the the revolutionary idea
that Watson and Crick were proposing
took root almost instantly because it
explains so much and within 10 years
Watson and Crick had a Nobel Prize now
the second revolution which I'll get to
a minute has taken most of the rest of
the century to turn out to turn around
our thinking and to turn it upside down
but let's look at the Watson and Crick
revolution of the distance of a
half-century Crick is no longer with us
and Watson is an elder statement of
science statesmen of science this is a
photo of Watson from Mariana cooks
wonderful new book titled faces of
science within a couple of decades
biochemists now calling themselves
molecular biologists had figured out
their relationship between DNA and
proteins by this time their relationship
is so well established that it's called
a central dogma of molecular biology it
simply says that the DNA codes for RNA
which is a copy of one of the DNA
strands and that the information in the
RNA is translated into protein now
here's a diagram that depicts the
process in a bit of a of greater detail
the blue double helix in the center in
the nucleus is the DNA and there it is
being copied into the red RNA molecule
each of which contains the information
for a protein the RNA is shipped out of
the nucleus to be decoded by ribosomes
these big machines down here and here's
the growing protein molecule there are
many components of a twenty different
amino acids and the and the information
in the RNA is we now know three base red
three bases at a time gradually
extending the
one amino acid at a time so what's a
gene until rather recently could simply
be represented as a segment of the DNA
the codes for approaching the protein
coding sequence is preceded by a
sequence that serves as a switch called
a promoter that wasn't known at
mid-century that took another 20 or 30
years and the promoter basically said
start transcribing the DNA here
chromosomes then we're thought to be
long strings of genes very much
compacted with proteins as I showed you
on the last slide this wonderful banded
structure at the top right is a
chromosome from a fruit fly it's really
a fruit fly salivary gland these
wonderful chromosomes develop this way
because they never separate the
chromosomes keep dividing but they stay
together and they form these big chains
and essentially the the deeply staining
parts are the sequences that code for
proteins and then there are more
extended connectors now the
representation of a chromosome on the
left is an artist's idea of course there
isn't just one little strand of DNA down
the center the DNA is there's yards and
yards of it and it's wound up very
tightly in this structure which is
actually an already replicated
chromosome this is more the shape of a
human chromosome or any dupa a
chromosome in any dividing cell the long
extended structures get compacted they
get wound up even more tightly they
divide and this is the last point of
connection when those points separate
the two daughter chromosomes will go to
separate cells by mid-century the
prevalent notion of evolution centered
on the well-known process of mutation
recombination and segregation the idea
is that genes changed by small mutation
keep your eye on the red and the blue
jeans that's a mutation
here's another mutation the new slightly
different versions are shuffled by
recombination I told you a bit earlier
that chromosomes shuffle parts exchange
parts and then they are there's a we
combined chromosomes and then they are
segregated to the progeny other kinds of
genetic changes were actually known at
this time but generally it wasn't
thought they weren't thought to
contribute much to evolution but wait
just a few years before the landmark
Watson and Crick DNA paper geneticist
Barbara McClintock announced her
discovery that certain genes could move
to new positions she called it
transposition
but unlike Watson and Crick's DNA
structure mclintock's discovery wasn't
exactly hailed immediately as one of the
great discoveries of the century to
geneticists who'd made whole careers of
mapping genes on chromosomes this is
kind of like saying that the kitchen
could occasionally jump into the Attic
when you weren't looking it just didn't
fit with their daily observation that
neither kitchens nor genes moved around
in fact the very ability to construct a
genetic map of a chromosome implies that
the genes i have fixed positions and
they don't change from generation to
generation so let me introduce you to
this unlikely revolutionary she was born
in 1902 and this picture probably dates
to her days at Cornell as a budding corn
geneticist she became famous at a young
age by identifying the individual corn
chromosomes later in the 1930s working
with a graduate student named Harriet
Creighton keep that name in mind she
provided the genetic linkage proved that
genetic geneticist linkage groups
correspondent to individual chromosomes
and that the recombination involved the
exchange of chromosome pieces as I
showed you on the previous slide but
when she started talking
jeans that moved that transpose from one
place to another this was about the
middle of their career she pretty much
lost everyone other than corn
researchers to home such unstable jeans
were familiar geneticists just didn't
know what to make of her assertion that
genes could move I didn't get to know
her until much later in her career when
she looked more like this and if you've
heard of her at all it might have been
because of the stamp which came out last
year I first met her when I was invited
to speak at the Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory about some very early DNA
sequencing work that I was doing I just
happened to run into her in the hall she
apologized for having missed my lecture
and I thought why would she be
apologizing to me I was just a lowly
postdoc she invited me to come down to
her laboratory and we talked for the
rest of the afternoon
I was totally intrigued she was quick
insightful and above all loosen at the
time I was a postdoc at a sister
department of the same institution that
she belonged to the Carnegie Institution
of Washington except that I was in
Baltimore so I went home and took down
the Carnegie yearbooks off the shelf
that's mostly where she published and
started reading mclintock's
work was purely genetic she had done
virtually all over work before today's
molecular techniques had been invented I
thought it was beautiful and I thought
it would be fascinating to actually
isolate study these jumping genes now at
the time that seemed like a far out
undertaking because no plant genes had
been cloned and actually people were
saying that you couldn't clone them
about this time I was offered a position
as a faculty member at the Carnegie
Institution and my first thought was how
I can do this it took a lot of years and
it was harder than I thought it would be
but eventually it happened now what I
would like to do is to show you exactly
how McClintock figured out the genes
jump even now I find it extraordinary
that she understood so much
from studying just the pigment and
starch patterns in corn kernels in
looking at their chromosomes now in the
early 1940s McClintock devised a method
to break chromosomes and she studied
what happens to their inheritance
patterns the short arm of chromosome 9
which is what you see here carries
several genes that affect how the kernel
looks and what kind of starch it has she
used a dominant allele of a color gene
that actually inhibited the development
of pigment so that the even when there
was a normally dominant allele this was
super dominant to that one and it was it
was designated ifour inhibitor the code
the genes that you show that I show you
in colored blocks are ones that are
required for pigment production and then
there's a third gene that I'll talk
about which is required for maturing the
pigment so when the chromosome breaks
the genes are lost in a piecemeal
fashion and so here when the I gene the
inhibitor gene is lost pigmented
segments develop sectors develop and
then when the next gene is lost it
uncovers the bronz gene so the
combination of C and the recessive
bronze allele give the bronze colored
sectors so on ears covered with kernels
that look like this she picked up a
kernel that looked like this quite
extraordinarily different now there's
actually another gene on this same
chromosome and that's important
genetically but it actually doesn't show
on this slide because it affects the the
starch composition but we'll leave it in
there because it makes the point what
McClintock figured out what what these
kernels have is just two kinds of
patches and that is that they have a
bronze patch and a colorless patch no
purple patches they're just rims at the
interfaces between those sectors and
they're purple because and that gives
you a clue that in fact all the genes
for the color production are still there
now what she found was that all of these
three genes consistently got lost
together and so she named the position
at which the chromosome broke the
importance of the waxey locus is that
she knew that the site of chromosome
breakage had to be closer to the very
center of the chromosome that white
circle here is the center it's called
it's the piece that connects the two
dividing chromosomes together there's a
whole long long arm of the chromosome
which I haven't represented what she
figured out was that what was happening
was that the chromosome was breaking
consistently at one site and she called
that site the dsr dissociation locus now
how did you figure out that the DES
could move well on years now you can see
the power of maize genetics on ears that
were covered with kernels like this she
picked up a kernel that looked like this
now the interesting thing here is that
now there are patches of color back but
then there in addition these interesting
little twin sectors so what's going on
here what McClintock figured out after
much careful analysis is that that this
chromosome was breaking the site that
was breaking the chromosome had actually
moved to a new place now by that time
she had also figured out that didn't
break chromosomes by itself but required
another gene which she called the
activator gene and we abbreviate that AC
to activate chromosome breakage at des a
C could be located somewhere far away on
same chromosome or another chromosome it
didn't matter when AC
send out its signal and broke the gene
or broke the chromosome then it
uncovered these colored patches these
small bronze sectors these small twin
sectors which are purple and bronze
however she also figured that out they
don't have a diagram of it but what she
figured out was that the two ends of
that newly broken chromosome stayed
together so that when the chromosomes
tried to separate they were attached at
their centers and they tended to break
and sometimes both of the dominant
alleles would go to one daughter cell
and that would leave the other daughter
cell with a recessive allele which gives
you the little bronze patches so that's
the result of one cell division and all
the daughter cells that come from one
side get two copies of the pigment gene
and all the chromosomes that go the
other way only have the recessive allele
and now if you see the stamp you know
what's on it so there they actually this
came out of my own files of copies of
her unpublished work and they even
reproduced her handwriting
there's the little D s and you can see
some of the genes that I talked about
there were other genes that she had on
here and this was the first diagram that
she drew for herself in her own notes
that showed how the D s moved to a new
position as I as I said the folks that
designed the stay of even reproduced
your handwriting now let me show you how
this esoteric stuff relates to more
things that are more familiar to you
you've all certainly seen what's now
called Indian core and it's corn that
has not only pigmented kernels but also
kernels that are variegated I don't know
whether you ever look closely but there
are stripes and spots sometimes more of
them sometimes less of them sometimes
larger sometimes smaller
the shapes of the spots and stripes
reflect how the various tissues grow
you've all seen this kind of variation
not just on corn kernels but the farmers
market but in flowers leaves virtually
any plant part as well as in animals
from butterfly wings to zebra stripes of
Dalmatian spots variegation signals that
a gene is working in some places and not
in others in these kernels a gene that
is needed to make the pigment is on in
the colored sectors and it's off in the
colorless sectors people had tried to
study the genetics of variation for a
long time back into the preceding
century it had made some progress but
most geneticists had kind of dismissed
them some of them even called them SiC
genes and thought they weren't we're
studying McClintock knew about the
earlier studies but unlike most of us
she never dismissed anything that
puzzled her she also knew that a friend
of hers and a fellow Corps geneticist by
the name of Marcus Rhodes had discovered
that a standard perfectly stable
colorless in the allele when combined
with the right genetic background would
give this kind of a pattern of
variegation and he called the gene he at
least identified that it was a single
gene that did the job and he called it
dotted because it made the spots appear
so she knew that and of course chance as
the old saw goes favors the prepared
mind McClintock identified a recombinant
chromosome that had the D s very close
to the C gene that's C for color and she
constructed a combination that I had a
recessive colorless mutation on the
other chromosome so when AC activated
chromosome breakage
it uncovered colorless patches among the
large number of kernels that looked like
this and had small colorless patches she
found just one that showed exactly the
burst pattern
it was colorless and had colored spots
very much like the kernels I just showed
you but Clinton figured out that at the
instigation of AC the DEA's had jumped
into the CG and now gave that colorless
background
but when Deus jumped again the gene went
back to being normal giving purple
sectors these elegant genetic
experiments explained the widespread
phenomenon of variegation by showing
that it was due to the transposition of
in this case D s into and then out of a
gene McClintock announces discovery at a
major scientific conference in 1951 in
her later years McClintock liked to tell
the story that people thought she was
crazy when she made this announcement
but by all accounts her colleagues
simply didn't know what to make of it by
that time she had made many important
genetic discoveries had been elected as
one of the first women members of the
National Academy of Sciences in fact the
story goes in some claim that it's
apocryphal that one of her colleagues
admitted bafflement but said that if
McClintock had said it was so it must be
so now another thirty years would pass
before
a.cian acquired a physical reality but
either in the knowledge nor the tools
existed at the time even when I took up
the challenge of cloning them in the
late 1970s it seemed a daunting
challenge because not a single plant
gene had been cloned yet but these
problems were eventually solved and I
cloned the first AC element in 1982 the
first publication appeared in 1983
coincidentally but only coincidentally
the Year McClintock received her
unshared Nobel Prize for her work
this is an electron micrograph that was
the very first visual evidence that AC
is a piece of DNA stuck in a gene this
is a DNA molecule one strand of which
came from a normal gene and one from a
mutant gene they had an AC in it the two
strands stick together throughout most
of their length except in this loop and
that's the AC element it's in one place
of one strand and not in the other it's
in the DNA that came from the mutant
with an AC in it and that's what it is
so what did these things turn out to be
well you remember that I told you that
gene is basically a DNA sequence that
codes for a protein AC turned out to be
a gene but a very special kind of gene
that codes for protein that is required
to transpose the gene itself it's called
a transpose ace the transpose ace cuts
the DNA and initiates the transposition
of the piece of DNA that it encloses
inside the special recognition sequences
so here it is snipping out the piece of
DNA and inserting it in a new location
so what's a dis it turned out to be AC
with a hole in a deletion it couldn't
jump on its own because it didn't have
an intact transposes gene but it could
jump if there was a trick if there was
an intact element anywhere in the genome
but the one that she that led to her
discovery was turned out to be a very
special kind of dsl iment it was one
inserted in inverted orientation in the
middle of another don't have time to
explain it but in fact the reason that
it broke chromosomes was because it had
both sequences on both both ends on both
strands
so it's time to leave this is kurzon
into the history of how transposons were
discovered and get back to the big
picture I gave you this simple view of a
gene as a protein coding sequence in
this view of chromosomes in which the
genes sit like beads on a string does
anybody remember puppet beads well that
was kind of the simple picture and that
became began to come apart in a serious
way when genes began to be cloned and
analyzed using the new gene cloning and
sequencing technologies that were
invented in the 1970s 80s and 90s so
let's start with the gene itself the
first thing I have to tell you is that
genes are generally in pieces often lots
of little pieces called exons separated
by stretches of DNA called introns this
was discovered by sticking the messenger
RNA molecule to its complimentary DNA
strand from which it was copy
surprisingly and this is just a drawing
of what's in the electron micrograph
there were long loops and it's the DNA
that was looping as if there were
sequences in the DNA that were
represented in the RNA molecule so
what's happening here what happens is
that the DNA is copied into an RNA
molecule reading right through the
introns and the exons but even as it's
being even as it's being synthesized
it's being stitched together and the
introns are clipped out just as you see
here and the exons are connected to each
other some genes are quite simple having
just a few exons but at the other
extreme there are very complicated genes
with more than a hundred exons and
everything in between so we're almost
finished making that some of these genes
extend over incredible lengths of DNA so
there's the messenger RNA as it's
actually made and one of the champions
champion genes has said drosophila
jannat sure it's the biggest one but
it's
impressive it has a hundred and sixteen
exons only 17 of which appear in the
messenger RNA taken 17 at a time the 116
exons could potentially give you more
than 38,000 different proteins and the
claim is that some 18,000 these are
actually made so think about this the
next time you read about the
disappointingly small number of genes in
human beings we have roughly the same
number of genes as a corn plant but each
of our genes codes for many different
proteins there was a time when part of
the genetic Dogma said that one gene
only codes for one protein that's gone
the concept of a gene is rather more
complicated than it used to be as well
next thing I have to tell you is the
genes even in pieces don't usually sit
next to each other like little beads on
a string not only are they complicated
but they're often very far apart so I'm
just giving you higher and higher
magnifications here at lower and lower
magnification sorry so it's G and I'm
compacting and showing the distance
between so what's in between now after
all I've been telling you perhaps you
won't be surprised to learn that most of
the other stuff is actually transpose
ons great blocks of them there are
actually two different kinds of
transposons there the transposons which
move as a piece of DNA and then there
are things called retrotransposons they
accomplish the same thing of movement
but they don't pick up the piece of DNA
they actually copy it into RNA and then
they copy it back into DNA and reinsert
someplace else
this clearly violates the central dogma
which says that the information only
flows from DNA to RNA so it's back again
so how do chromosomes change over time
how do they evolve
here's a published diagram that compares
a tiny section of a maize chromosome to
a corresponding section of a chromosome
in sorghum a close relative of corn
the gray bars connect the similar genes
what you can see is that the genes are
pretty much the same notice first that
they're a little red and purple
triangles everywhere I use little red
triangles to represent the McClintock
type transposons and they're everywhere
they're inside of genes they're upstream
of genes they're downstream of genes
these big long blocks of
retrotransposons are actually located in
between genes but you can see up at the
top here two genes in the sorghum genome
that look very much alike that's
actually a duplication so duplications
transpositions and other kinds of
rearrangements separate these two
closely related species so now the most
striking difference between maize and
sorghum is these blocks of
retrotransposons very big big big blocks
they are just abbreviated and
represented by these triangles so in
fact they're retrotransposons inserted
inside of retrotransposons inside
retrotransposons often uninterrupted for
very long stretches by genius now lest
you think that plants are different from
nanos take a look at this little gene
reagent in mice and people and she she
have any arrogance left it should be
gone by now the genes are the same
although not exactly pretty close in
fact of your 40,000 genes or so most are
similar enough to those in mice to be
recognizably related sometimes nearly
identical the spaces between them inside
of them they're stuffed with transposon
retrotransposons and all kinds of small
duplications in
different in every species those are
indicated by the various colors in the
lower diagrams here so even though the
gene sequences are recognisably similar
what's between them is very different
here's a fascinating comparison of the
mouse and human chromosomes it gives you
a good feel for how chromosome pieces
get shuffled over evolutionary time each
human chromosome is represented by a
slightly different color on the right
side of the diagram the location of the
similar sequences is in the mouse genome
is shown with the same color on the left
side and you can appreciate the
scrambling so for example mouse
chromosome one has sequence blocks that
are similar to human chromosome six to
eighteen and one it's a very coarse map
and the scrambling actually goes down to
a very fine level please note that this
doesn't mean that the mouse has
scrambled human genome yeah if you could
represent the the its closest ancestor
from which both lineages diverged in
evolution you would see that there would
be a different scrambled complement of
the progenitors genes in humans and in
mice so here's how our views of heredity
have changed almost unimaginably over
the last century before Mendel the field
was dominated by biome attrition who
generally thought the properties of
parents were mixed together kind of like
wine and water so that the offers
offspring were a blend of their parents
traits and that's true for some but not
all so what I mean by that is that
sometimes there isn't a dominant in a
recessive allele
but there's codominance that in fact the
f1 is different from both parent
parentals parental phenotypes now
Mendel disabused us of the notion that
this is the way genes worked although
his findings didn't really come to
influence genetics until well into the
20th scent
by the middle of the 20th century the
idea that there were units of heredity
which were called genes was
well-established genes were known to be
co-located on chromosomes which
recombined before being distributed
progeny so mutation recombination
segregation were generally viewed as the
focus the forces that drove Darwinian
evolution this view actually persisted
well into the second half of the 20th
century so another half century and many
many technological revolutions Linette
later the view of how genes and genomes
are structured and evolve has changed
radically
what earlier geneticists learned is
still true genes can change by small
mutation of a single nucleotide a single
letter of the DNA's for elf the
four-letter alphabet but they also
changed by duplications and deletions
both small and large as well as
transposition events and rearrangements
here's how one might think about genome
evolution today so there's a
transposition event another
transposition event a little
transposition into the middle of a gene
a duplication
a retro transposon moving and then
duplicating
it's another little batch of transpose
ax below that's coming in but then great
big pieces of DNA actually move as well
and this is how this shuffling that you
saw in the mouse in human genomes occurs
remarkably different picture
how often do any of these changes happen
well if you're just looking at one small
stretch of DNA you might have to wait a
million years or so to see a change but
if you ask about the whole genome then
it's likely that some differences arise
every time or just about every time the
genome is copied the result is that any
two people in the population have
different enough DNA that the forensic
scientist needs sample only a tiny
fraction of it to figure out whether
your DNA does or doesn't match that
recovered from the crime scene so genes
and genomes are remarkably plastic and
changing all the time the mystery today
is why it took so long to figure this
out why are genomes
full of jumping genes able to hang
together reliably enough to have
convinced early geneticist that genes
don't move now finally there's a growing
realization that genes are not like
books in the library each its own
self-contained packet of information the
more like an enter the interconnected
websites of the Internet expression of
one gene influences that of many gene
and his turn in turn influenced by
expression of others genes don't talk to
each other directly as you know a gene
is only an information repository but
the protein encoded by a gene can
influence expression of another gene
quite directly if it's involved in the
immediate process of activating its
transcription or it can influence other
genes very indirectly through its
participation in cellular processes that
in turn affect expression of genes
nonetheless the genes are all tied
together in a web of interactions we
increasingly call these gene networks
what I'm showing you here is a network
of gene interactions extracted from
contemporary detailed measurements of
gene expression levels microarray data
this is work I've been doing with
several physicists to ask whether it's
possible to extract information about
such interactions for measuring the
changes in expression level levels of
many genes thousands of them over time
but what the future holds is even more
complicated because each of these simple
lines in this diagram represents a
complex series of actors proteins and
small molecules like hormones that carry
on the conversations in cells and
between cells in the organism as a whole
I end with my own personal tribute to
this remarkable scientist Barbara
McClintock who understood the dynamism
of genes and genomes long before most of
us were ready to think about it she even
had the concept of gene networks I have
a vivid recollection of one conversation
which she asked sharply how is it that a
mutation doesn't completely disrupt an
organism these of course are my words at
this distance in time but what
fascinated and puzzled her was how
everything in organisms was so
interconnected that many gene
disruptions could be absorbed and
accommodating if you think about a
machine decided by a human take a car
engine there aren't all that many parts
that you could eliminate at random and
still have a working machine McClintock
was a remarkable intellect and I found
myself extremely fortunate to have known
and worked with her she generally shared
her knowledge generously shared her
knowledge and her fascinating genetic
materials with me as I began to imagine
that I could capture and study these
elusive jumping genes and she spared no
criticism either although she did not
know the techniques of the molecular
biologists
indeed she was already long retired by
the time they were invented she stayed
informed reading papers and attending
scientific conferences to the end of her
life this photo dates from the early
1980s when she first came down to
Baltimore to visit my laboratory and
sure he here she is
years later frailer but still on
Stanny what these bands on gels meant
and helping interpret the results in
1990 I was approached by John Engels the
head of the Cold Spring Harbor press
with the idea of putting together a
volume in honor of Barbara's upcoming
90th birthday I took on this
extraordinary project with David
Botstein who was himself an early
discoverer of transposons and bacterial
viruses we worried all through the
project how Barbara would react very
simply whether she would live to see its
completion she did and we gathered
meaning those who contributed to the
book on her 90th birthday to present it
we'd managed to keep it as complete
secret this celebration took place at
Jim Watson's house here we are gathered
on his fourth front porch there were
many people standing around all around
the porch let me just point out a couple
of people lots of it by the way was then
still director of the Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory where the Carnegie
Institution of Washington which had long
since closed its genetics department
continued to maintain a laboratory from
McClintock until her death just to point
out a couple of people remember I told
you remember the name Harriet Creighton
this was McClintock's co-author on the
1931 paper that first made her famous
this is my co-editor David Botstein who
is now at Princeton and this is Bruce
Alberts Barbara's longtime champion and
the immediate past president of National
Academy of Sciences and I had begun to
read the preface to her at first she
joked a bit making a few self
disparaging wisecracks and then she grew
silent fascinating it was a hit she
couldn't quite believe it and though she
had complained about having to dress up
and go out and be with people she said
it was her best birthday ever she was
gone a few months later leaving the
world to absorb in the future what she
had understood
treat earlier that's it for time
tomorrow we take on genetically modified
foods and John has agreed to mediate
questions yeah so uh we've got as I
understand it 15 minutes left on the
tape that they're making for posterity
so that does give us time for some for a
few questions for Nina there's one right
here you have to interpret them yeah
yeah well otherwise I'll just wanna make
sure everybody heard the question
understands the question yeah so the
question I believe is roughly if if the
genome really is this dynamic and
there's all this shuffling going on how
can there be that much movement and
rearrangement and you don't screw up the
things that you basically have to do to
survive the answer is we don't know but
the fact of the matter is it matters
more what genes you have than where they
are that's probably the simplest answer
but it's not very deep
so the question is in specific reference
to what Nina was showing in terms of the
introns and exons and the splicing that
happens in the production of the
messenger RNA how does that actually
happen how does it how does our body do
that and actually one of with the right
thing at the end of the day that's
really a remarkable process there's
usually an exact dinucleotide there's a
donor site and a receptor site but these
are dinucleotides and there's lots and
lots of copies of those so there's
actually a more complicated there's a
whole machine that does this okay and it
catches the first site cuts it and then
recognizes sequences right in the intron
and then Clips it attaches it to the
next site now it's not a perfect process
but good enough and so the other part of
it is that so there are recognition
sequences at the ends of the intron and
there are usually recognition sequences
in the middle the the whole thing forms
a lariat at one point and then finishes
the processing event but as I said
mistakes are made a lot of the time
because it's not constrained heavily and
so there's a there are layers of
proofreading and one of the most
remarkable things that has been
rediscovered relatively recently is that
if the coding sequence for the protein
isn't right the RNA gets trashed before
it gets out of the nucleus so there's
this huge turnover much of the RNA
that's made
is degraded it's proof read repeatedly
and only if it's right and the coding
sequences intact
does it get out it is a really awesome
process and I can't say that we
understand every detail of it but it is
remarkable I'll try to translate that
I'm not familiar with this so I may or
may not get it right but it's question
of bio photon emission from the DNA as a
mechanism of communication to other
other parts of the cell to to other
other work so you say that it's actually
light that is emitted by the DNA they
communicated your stunt you've stumped
me I don't know I'm not even familiar
with that
series that they have on regulations now
you got another hour so the question is
is if we could comment on on the process
of DNA methylation which is a chemical
modification of the DNA and its role in
actually controlling the movement and
the reshuffling of these various
transpose abilities yes the quick answer
is yes that's now a whole field of
epigenetics but I will tell you that
that's one of the things that McClintock
actually was one of the two earliest
observers of and that's what was a very
active area of research in my lab and
basically what she had reported and the
other person by the way is Mary Lyon who
studied chromosome x chromosome
inactivation basically what McClintock
observed with transposons is sometimes
they would disappear they would go out
as if they'd been deleted but then a few
generations later in a few kernels
they'd come on again so to make it a
long story pretty short what we
understand today is that there's a whole
nother layer of genetics which is called
epigenetics and it's that inactivation
is mediated by the production a little
tiny RNA molecules they're called
silencing RNAs and micro RNAs and they
go back and they trigger of methylation
in an activation so folding up of that
piece of chromosome so part of the
answer to why geneticists didn't see
these transposons is that they're
silenced folded up and recombination
doesn't happen it happens in the
unfolded gene regions so they act like
they're not there and they're very
stable very interesting area of research
research and it wasn't in fact when I
started working on it it was really
anybody that worked on methylation was
couldn't possibly be considered a Syria
scientists and now it's a hole it's
really interesting the question here
touches back to the earlier question of
the splicing of the messenger RNA and
the connection of the exons to make the
complete messenger RNA and in these ones
where you've actually got this sort of
combinatorial process right where there
are many many exons and you select a
subset of them and compact them together
how deterministic is that how well
regulated and and how are those
seventeen actually selected from those
1,000 some odd exons that's a really
active area of research and let me give
you the simple answer and that is that
you can imagine that if you can go from
exon 1 to exon 2 you might be able to
skip over exon 2 the Exxon 4 right and
so the process basically makes
alternative combinations of the exons
and how well regulated it is there are
cases for example the sexuality the the
femaleness or maleness of drosophila is
determined by alternative splicing
extremely well regulated in other cases
we don't know there may be a background
noise level of incorrect processing that
is then trashed in other cases it may be
very well regulated the thing that
really defies it makes it very difficult
to to nail down especially in humans is
that it's very hard
to figure out whether a particular
combination is actually functional or
whether you can detect it in the RNA but
how do you figure out when you have
multiple overlapping things like that
how do you do genetics on it the other
element I talked to you about AC but the
element that I've studied most
thoroughly if McClintock's elements is
an SP mo and we discovered that this one
gene had four overlapping transcripts
and we had to give up classical genetics
because all we got was deletion
mutations so what we did was ended up
reconstructing taking two of these
transcripts at a time and asking which
pair was required for transposition
those are experiments that are very
difficult to do in people but you can do
them in plants
other question is are there are there
some genes or clusters of genes that
have such an important function or or
maybe a function that's not robust to to
this type of translocation where we're
actually this rearrangement process for
translocation process is silenced in
particular regions of the genome it's a
really interesting question I'm not sure
that was the question but however it
came out okay I think that when he was
asking Ridge '''l II was are there genes
that are so strongly concerned that they
can't change and the answer to that is
yes it's a full spectrum of them there
are some that are so recognizable but
they're conserved by function so for
example plants have hemoglobin genes and
people have hemoglobin genes what's a
hemoglobin gene it's a gene whose
structure interacts very strongly with
oxygen and because it's actually
mediated by a an iron molecule but the
molecule is so similar it's so
constrained by the necessity to bind
oxygen
although plants and animals use them for
completely different reason for living
different purposes but there
recognizably similar there are other
genes that are almost identical and
there are others that diverge very
rapidly so the question the other
question your question or rephrasing of
his question was are there areas of the
genome that where the arrangement is so
important that they're left alone the
answer is yes and moreover it's even
more interesting than that because
recently it's been discovered that there
are portions of the genome that evolve
faster than others so by measures of
single base changes transpose
rearrangements everything else they stay
they have lower rates of change than
others how does that happen don't know
hardest to you but you got to the age
part I was just gonna say yes indeed the
whole machinery that does this that
allows parts of it to unwrap and it
actually separates DNA strands is
remarkable
so there are there are enzymes that
actually allow strands to penetrate so
though they'll divide the DNA hold on to
the ends and then seal it up again
that's happening all the time and the
remarkable thing is that if you knock
out one of the enzymes that is
constantly reconnecting the DNA even as
it's replicating and dividing and
getting repackaged the genome gets
traveled almost immediately a fellow bud
and fred alt has done some incredible
experiments where he essentially painted
the chromosomes with fluorescent dyes
different ones and then and then watched
what happens to these chromosomes when
you knock out an enzyme that reconnects
broken blunt broken ends and almost
immediately you get scrambled
chromosomes so this is a process see -
we need to stop and give me - one more
round of applause and encourage
and what a great army and and I would
like to encourage everyone to come back
tomorrow night there's one more one more
lecture in this series